well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Tuesday May the twenty
second 20:18 session in our series on
entrepreneurship and Asian high-tech
industries
I'm Richard Dasher I direct the US Asia
technology management that are we
produced this series with support from
our member companies which include
Bridgestone Corporation brilliant hope
incorporated means to be sure a search
Institute NEC corporation and beat some
a Khan University so I'm very happy that
you can all come today and I hope you'll
plan to stay after our formal session is
over
we will have some refreshments outside
and be sure and meet our panelists so we
always try to have one session in these
series on entrepreneurship to look at
the the whole situation with social
entrepreneurship and I think that we
have a great focus for our session this
year on social entrepreneurship which is
really the United Nations sustainable
development goals and how both
Technology Development and social
entrepreneurship are important ways in
which to approach those goals we've got
a great panel to talk about this sitting
closest to me is MS Radhika Shah and
Radhika I know as the co-president of
Stanford angels and entrepreneurs India
and Radhika is also and an entrepreneur
so here here I correct sorry about that
that's but there is a chapter in India
yes and why that but okay Paula's doing
that okay mutual friends Radhika is also
an advisor on the United Nations
strategic development goals and so she
will talk considerably about that
she's an advisor to she's a founding
chair of the technology advisory groups
for the Stanford Honda Center on Human
Rights and she's said
the international advisory network for
business and human rights Resource
Center
she's been an advisor and then the
mentor and a judge at various
accelerator programs such as star Dex
here and also impact experienced Skydeck
labs at berkeley illumine capital a fund
of impact funds and we're really happy
that radhika can be with us she's got a
master's in computer science from
Stanford and an MBA from Berkeley so
that's why you wind up mentoring at both
schools and also with us today is mr.
Icahn Gandhi and Rican is co-founder and
executive director of digital green
which is a global development
organization that is really aimed at
empowering small holder farmers to
really get out of poverty by harnessing
technology and also by doing grass level
partnerships he started this career at
Oracle he later joined Microsoft
Research
he has traveled extensively around the
rural communities in India and really
started this I guess in 2006 this
project really comes from back then so
I'm going to ask each of our panelists
to give us some prepared remarks and
after they both give them prepared
remarks I'll ask one or two questions to
get the discussion going and then it'll
be Q&A so there'll be plenty of
opportunity for you to have an
interactive part in this session so
radical why don't you go first your
slides are sure to be here back in
Richards class one of my favorite places
on campus and with an awesome Ashoka
fellow Rickon
I'll start by a little bit of context on
the sustainable development goals in
September 2015
several world leaders almost all world
leaders gathered at UN headquarters in
New York and came up with one of the
most ambitious set of goals ever
these calls unify development human
rights and looking at climate change the
very comprehensive things like
eliminating poverty hunger providing
quality access of education water energy
to all every single world citizen in the
next 15 years now 13 years from now and
not just that all the world leaders
committed to making this happen and have
started initiative so it's a very key
moment right now these goals are also
about leaving no one behind that is very
unique and different than past goals and
also they're very Universal in that it's
the recognition that we are at a crisis
point in the world both on where
inequality is how extreme it is and
climate change where the issues are not
just in developing parts of the world
the different issues in every part of
the world in America in Europe in India
in Africa so that recognition is very
important and also the thinking that
let's look at solutions local as well as
global and let's all collaborate to make
these things happen
so these goals we have social economic
and environmental goals and the other
unique thing is these goals recognize
that there's an integrated aspect here
when you work on water problems that
impacts women when you work when you
work on health when you work on energy
it impacts poverty is a recognition
about the interlinked nests of these
goals so today we'll look at two two
livers that are very powerful in helping
advance these goals and one of them is
social entrepreneurship social
entrepreneurs have actually been working
for a long long time on these goals some
people like Rickon and Ashoka fellows
other shaka fellows echoing green
fellows they've been looking at the
biggest challenges in society they've
been tackling change and coming up with
amazing innovations and this is going to
be critical that this way of looking at
social and environmental missions and
bringing the spirit of entrepreneurship
is going to be very important if we are
to come up with a disruptive kind of
innovations that are nonlinear that
really scale at a global level if we are
to come up with those social
entrepreneurship is going to be critical
and we'll need to really bring this make
this kind of
way of doing things and norm and make it
much more mainstream and this is where
people like Rickon are going to be the
Trailblazers to change the world and the
world needs many more changemakers and
as Ashoka would say it's the moment for
everyone to be a change maker it's it's
That moment when all of us need to be
part of this movement and on different
friend many people ask why what's what's
special about this moment these as DG's
the sustainable development goals have
been enshrined as rights in the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
for a long long time so so what if
people have come up and created this
goals and what is different is that it's
one thing to have these in some
documents but it's very different when
there is a time frame when these are
reframed as goals when all the leaders
come together and say we're going to
make this happen and start taking action
and what is important is that many
organizations have started around these
goals and for the first time we have a
universal language and a framework that
all of us understand and agree on that
word is social change and sub-sub kind
of it's a taxonomy with sub levels as
well and that is really changing how we
are doing things now the very unique
thing that's happening at this moment in
the world is technology is becoming the
new oil of the economy it is becoming a
game changer in good and bad ways we can
there are of course amazing things we
can do a technology but a lot of
negative externalities we need to
recognize we need to think of how to use
technology in a accountable and
responsible way and of course do you
mean it makes it smoother or is it like
oil I mean that it makes it more smooth
and faster and more than that it is
becoming the infrastructure for
everything we do rather than technology
as a sector ok it's becoming something
that every sector uses as infrastructure
and it's becoming a critical piece of
the infrastructure like without
electricity and oil broadly like without
fuel we almost can't do anything ok it's
becoming embedded in almost everything
we do so in that sense it is becoming
kind of them the bedrock of sorts ok
then how can we leverage technology is
accelerant or game changes what we will
look at today and there's a third thing
happening which puts it as a very
critical inflection point at this moment
in the world young people like you're a
very very passionate about positive
change they care a lot about what
happens to the world what happens to
people around them they're demanding the
change so these three things put us at a
very yes thanks to it so there are two
sides to technology I'm to jump in so
one of the levers for social
entrepreneurship the other lever we
touched on is technology technology can
I'm going to jump in a few examples on
how it can be a positive game-changer
one example is from India today we go to
focus on India so I'm going to talk
about a couple of India focus examples
and we will come back to more your dose
is an organization in India in the other
country where there is a lot of social
taboo about mental health people don't
go to psychologists but now this social
entrepreneur has managed to solve that
problem because leveraging the anonymity
of the internet now she's connecting
patients who with care providers have a
personalized relationship but to keep
the anonymity so this is something that
was not possible before similarly I just
learned recently that there is it again
looking at India there's technologies
whereby satellite imaging one could just
fit technology predict what is happening
which areas are more poverty what is
happening with the rate of urban sprawl
all of this just by satellite images and
extrapolating from that so it's
fascinating what's happening with
technology on the negative side we of
course live in an age of fake news
misinformation there is so much
confusion people don't know what to
trust I've touched on again of Asia
example South Asia example the Rohingya
crisis which is one of the worst refugee
crisis right now in the world
partially some of us believe a key
factor has been that a lot of people in
that part of the world Myanmar have been
receiving news mainly from social media
and they've been receiving a lot of
negative news witches or information
which has led to xenophobia against
certain ethnic groups and it's led to
one of the biggest humanitarian crises
in the world and this is an example
where technology social media can
to find negative messaging as well so
the questions are that Tech has an
acceleration is a way of accelerating
and being foundational in achieving all
the STG is how key is its role the other
question is will the digital divide kind
of increase with technology and increase
inequality or will it be an equalizer if
we could dump virtual listing so some of
the key factors in achieving the SDGs
are high capital needs the SDG is going
to need the the capital gap is 2.5
trillion dollars right now if you need a
lot of money that's just not there in
government aid you and funding and such
technology could be a key factor in
reducing this gap the kind of
innovations we're talking about could
bring down the capital needs now this
policy change we need inclusive
integrated sustainable policy and this
is an area with social entrepreneurs
like Rickon who bring change in how we
think could actually create social
movements that influence policy again we
need nonlinear scalable innovation and
tech could be a huge factor there and
then we need to shift how people think
and that again is the area where social
entrepreneurs can have a huge influence
we need to look have systemic change in
how we think about each other about
environment and then we need deep
collaboration across sectors so origin X
so I will jump into a few examples and
then wrap up um III have have some
examples from Africa I won't get into
I'll just touch on the India examples
one example of this kind of systems
change where social entrepreneur is
leveraging technology very powerfully
but also changing the culture and
creating many more social entrepreneur
minded people is internet sati
this is a collaborative of Google and
the Tata trust in India it was born as a
20% project of a Google employee and
this is transforming the role of women
what it is doing in in some parts of
rural India there are gender gender
cultural issues where people think that
women are not tech savvy now this this
kind of initiative is making women the
people who bring the Internet to their
villages the women are trained on
technology and internet access they
bring it to their villages they're
trained
in the villages they become the ones who
teach their husbands how to have access
to good farming techniques that are the
mother-in-law's how to have good recipes
so suddenly is a shift in how women are
viewed and they're viewed as a
tech-savvy ones and this initiative was
scaled to a large number of so I don't
want to get my facts wrong 15 million
women across India are affected by this
and it's in 150,000 villages and this is
really really catching on like fire it's
a platform on which many other services
can be built and this is an example
where digital literacy of women and
putting them in the leadership roles
what it can achieve now the example is
CG Nats whare again is one where a BBC
journalist social entrepreneur went to
tribal India the most vulnerable people
in India and he taught them citizen
journalism a few of them in each village
and empowered them with a amazing
solution where they don't even have
smartphones are basic phones so all the
citizen journalist has to do is audio
record what they're seeing in the
village just leave a voicemail why are
basic phone yeah and then this happens
all over India and then the next bed is
a loaded on the server and any person
living in a tribal indigenous community
in any part of India can this dial a
number and the hear was happening all
over this is transforming what's
happening the voice is getting heard not
just that the issues that are arising
human rights issues and such are being
heard by the nation by various people in
is transforming their lives but one
common thing in both of this it's not
just social entrepreneurs who started
this they have empowered so many more
changemakers via technology and then
this thing's happening at the national
level as well in India other ideas
transformed what happens to half a
billion people other ID is a biometrics
based digital ID it's an amazing
experiment in India where now so many
Indians who did not have an identity
have a legal identity hence their access
to so many services including like food
rations banking services even if they
are illiterate they could still do this
via biometrics it's transforming their
lives and
the example is in Kenya where Kenya is
looking the UN and the government are
looking to leverage tech innovation to
provide universal health care to every
Canyon and they want to partner with
tech providers and doing amazing work
there and then I want to touch on
samasource there's also things happening
across countries across continents
summer sauce is a local organization
here which is doing work in India Africa
it is fascinating in that it brings
digital micro work little bits of
digital work from places like Silicon
Valley to the most vulnerable
communities in rural India in
sub-saharan Africa it's transforming how
how we are able to engage with each
other all of this is done via the
internet and then finally I want to
touch on Google oceans Google Earth
these are global technology innovations
they're global transformations are
happening by mapping the oceans with
technology that helps us understand
where is deforestation happening that is
enabling global collaboration and
transformation and I just want to wrap
up with a call to action but this is a
moment let's come together as a global
community to collaborate to innovate to
do whatever we can in the true spirit of
social entrepreneurship you don't need
to be a classic social entrepreneur it's
a way of thinking and let's leverage
technology in an intentional thoughtful
responsible manner to advance this
global goes our other goals they are not
the UN's goals and not the government
leaders they're each and every world
citizen scotts okay thanks very much
Radhika as I'm setting up the next
presentation I'd like to ask how do you
see a definition for social
entrepreneurship that is a very
interesting question that have given a
lot of thought to Richa okay because
here in Silicon Valley
entrepreneurship is started building a
successful business and making money and
social entrepreneurship is often thought
of as to make money and achieve goals or
a non profit but to me again I I have
some deep connection history with Ashoka
I had started the form of Silicon Valley
chapter for Shakur so this is a topic I
discussed with some
shocker staff and I I see social
entrepreneurship as a way of people who
innovate a way of innovating a way of
tackling some of the biggest challenges
being resourceful like an entrepreneur
is in the in the term entrepreneur means
kind of resourceful innovator it doesn't
have anything to do with making money's
there is one way of scaling the other
ways and it doesn't matter if you're a
non-profit or a for-profit that's a
sleeker structure
someone who kind of looks at big
challenges and cares about mission and
noting manhood let me push it a little
how's that different from philanthropy
it's different because in philanthropy
you come in with a mindset of what can i
fund right and you're the money is what
can I do what can I change yeah not what
can i fund what problem can attack you
and what can I change whether it's
changing a norm where they're changing a
system in some manner money is just a
resource okay so let's move on and when
I come back to this kind of topic but
riffing all through your slides okay so
just tell me what that sure to have me
rabbika as well for organizing it's
great to be with all of you guys
15 years ago I would never think that I
would be on such a panel 15 years ago I
was here visiting Stanford to
potentially come here for grad school in
aerospace engineering with because I had
dreams of going to space I didn't come
here I'm at the MIT but I was sort of
wanting to put together my own astronaut
PlayBook by studying computer science
aerospace engineering getting a pilot
license and was about to enlist in the
US Air Force when I landed up in a very
different place with a very different
type of hero right what really inspired
me about astronauts was with their
unique combination of brains and brawn
to make like what seemed impossible
possible and what I landed up in was
rural India back in 2006 with some
friends from college who are trying to
start up a biodiesel venture with some
farming communities in rural America
essentially to convince them to grow
oil-bearing crops that could be
esterified into biodiesel and what was
interesting was this community of
farmers are really small farmers these
are farmers that just have half an acre
to an acre worth of land earned just one
to two dollars per day but in totality
are producing the second highest farm
output in the world and the way that
they do that is the fact that sixty
percent of India's 1.2 billion
population depends still on agriculture
as a major source of its livelihoods and
about 80 percent of these farmers are
small farmers and the market potential
is huge right they're producing about
118 billion dollars worth of production
and most of this production is just
being sold in informal marketplaces in a
pretty ad hoc manner so what we started
off with was back in 2006 initially as a
part of Microsoft Research I joined
forces with them after this startup
venture kind of flopped after six months
because basically it didn't make sense
for farmers to convert their land from
food crops to oil-bearing crops when
they still needed food to be eaten for
themselves and so then I joined up with
Microsoft Research in Banglore in a
group looking at technology for emerging
markets which had a mandate to think
about is there a role of Technology in
different areas of development from
microfinance to education to healthcare
and in our case agriculture and what we
wanted to see is is it a role for
technology in the broadest possible
sense thinking about like even the pen
and paper as being a form of technology
all the way to say a tablet computer and
what ended up us landing on was the use
of videos videos that were be produced
by farmers for farmers to share best egg
recalled practices with each other very
similar to say the YouTube experience
where all of us generally gravitate to
our own niche communities online
similarly trying to recreate that
atmosphere
in an asynchronous way where videos
would be produced offline just using
camcorders would be stored on a kind of
repository online including on YouTube
and then be available offline on mobile
projectors that could be screened
amongst local communities and where data
and feedback could be captured about
what videos farmers were watching what
practices they ultimately did and what
practice what questions or issues they
might have had afterwards so can I ask
that was this because of worried the
older generations were dying off and
younger generations weren't starting or
was this really because not many farmers
were really using best practices yeah
basically the latter and it's a huge
business of trying to train farmers on
ways to boost their productivity
especially in the face of like climate
change and market sort of you know
change and and the government of India
for instance has one of the largest
extension forces in the world which is
basically the adult education of farmers
they have about 200,000 odd individuals
who just go around to farmers as fields
to demonstrate here's a new seed variety
here's a fertilizer here's how you
connect with markets and they do this
all through face to face means and this
use of videos was essentially meant to
complement the work that they were
already doing and to essentially improve
their efficiency and we ran some
randomized control trials where we found
that this approach could basically save
these extension programs of say the
government basically 1/10 of their cost
to get one more farmer to adopt one new
practice using these videos ok so so far
we've scaled this approach now to about
one and a half million farmers across
17,000 villages
largely across South Asia but also into
parts of Africa including like an
Ethiopian the rest what we do is we do
we partner with mostly local government
like Ministry of Rural Development in
India has a large-scale program of
training farmers and they use these
videos again by farmers for farmers to
improve their efficiency and similarly
in Ethiopia we work with the Ministry of
Agriculture and do
something very similar but so that's
what we started with and we were doing
that basically from 2006 to basically
about two years ago we were seeing
ourselves as this video based enabler
essentially like a YouTube for these
farmers and for these extension programs
that we're trying to train these farmers
on ways to boost their production but we
realized it was that information alone
isn't going to create the final net
income benefit that these farmers
ultimately need to see in their pockets
we found is in fact through our
randomized control trials was that this
approach was was creating this 10x
improvement in efficiency and was
resulting in gains of of income of about
21 percent but this was not sufficiently
transformative for these farmers to
really be like hey maybe I don't want to
be a farmer anymore maybe I want to
graduate well how is that gonna happen
well you got to do stuff beyond
information and you got to go beyond
just the production part of Agriculture
and think about those next hops that are
before production of how do I access
seeds and fertilizers and the next stop
about how I access output markets to
actually take my produce sell it at
market and get more money for it so the
way that farmers generally do that in
terms of the latter thing of how do I
take say I boosted my production by
getting access to amazing information
whether in video or non video form like
how do I go to market well for
perishable produce like fruits and
vegetables farmers in India have just a
couple of options either they can sell
the top 10% of their produce in their
local community and they'll get a great
price for it they can sit on the
roadside and try to sell like some small
quantities of produce or they can take a
bus a bicycle or maybe a fellow persons
like motor bike to the nearby wholesale
market which is called a Monday in India
and and usually those markets are just
about like five to 20 kilometers in
distance from these farmers but it costs
money it costs them generally
about 45% of the value of their produce
just on transportation and seven to
eight hours worth of time right and so
and for a perishable commodity it's like
fruits and vegetables it's a race
against time either you get your produce
to market and you get it sold or it's
worthless by the same day so what we
ended up creating was a service that we
call loop which you can think of as
essentially an uber pool for fruits and
vegetables essentially farmers requests
pickups for their fruit and vegetable
harvests we match that to nearby
transporters in the local vicinity
everything from a small rickshaw to a 1
to 2 ton truck that is then assigned to
go follow a route make the pickups from
these farmers as doorsteps move the
produce to wholesale markets and
complete the sale of this produce and
pay them back via mobile money there's
now a service in India called Paytm that
is very popular for these farmers to get
same-day payments and what we're in now
in the process of doing is essentially
taking what began as a non-profit
initiative from 2006 to 2016 - now in
the process of saying that you know
these farmers didn't need that basic
boost in production and in some ways we
actually were successful at massive
scale of about one and a half million
farmers but now these farmers is needs
have changed that are transforming just
like the economy of India is changing
there's so much more demand from the
middle class and these rural communities
for this fruit and vegetable produce
that farming no longer needs to be seen
as like a vocation of subsistence but
can ash actually be something that is a
commercially viable business for them
and for us and so we're becoming a
social enterprise by essentially
converting this loop service into a
for-profit
we're basically farmers pay for their
share of the transportation and the pot
buyers also pay because we're giving
them consistently higher volumes of the
produce that they need and so so
we are a social enterprise within the
definition that we are not profitable at
the moment and that's why we're kind of
in the red but we anticipate that we
will be in the next two years by
basically hitting around a hundred and
fifty-one million dollars of annual
sales of taking this farmers as produce
to market with just even four hundred
thousand farmers as produce so far what
we reached is about twenty five thousand
farmers and if converted about twenty
twelve million dollars worth of produce
so we're kind of already on this journey
and next slide what we're essentially
trying to to do is to see can we
reimagine the way that people think
about agricultural development and
supply chain development generally if
you are a Starbucks or you're a Cargill
type of agricultural company that's
sourcing some commodity you start from
yourself as the buyer and then you
source from catchment areas of farmers
who can supply to you what we're trying
to say is can we do this in Reverse can
we make it as efficient as possible for
these farmers to connect with first top
markets and then connect them with first
these local wholesale markets and then
these bigger buyers so that these
farmers can then be connected to this
global agricultural and food system that
we are all part of and and that's what
we think is is our ultimate impact
that's that's okay if you want to show
the video oh yes this is a short video
only 55 seconds that you know will give
you just a kind of a sense of how the
luke service works it's really basic
right as I described it's you know the
first step is essentially that these
farmers are almost on an every other day
basis are harvesting produce they then
like make these pickup requests that I
have so much so many bags of produce we
assign a truck to make the pickups they
load the produce onto a shared vehicle
reduces the amortized costs for each of
them the produce goes to wholesale
markets its sold for money that money is
then digitized by Paytm
and then the money then shows back into
the accounts of these farmers and that's
it okay so I'm curious how did things
work before you brought in loot
there were middlemen right who would do
the delivery and so forth and in fact my
understanding is that in many places in
Southeast Asia they're kind of taking
most of the money and the farmers don't
get anything yeah so in the case of the
fruit and vegetable marketplace actually
there's not too many middlemen because
the volumes are very small you're a half
acre farmer who's growing like say
squash or eggplant essentially you're
harvesting maybe thirty to a hundred
kilos of this produce every other day in
season now that is not attractive for
even a middleman until I come and help
ping and steal stuff from you it's like
nothing and so for like the farmers
actually for them it's actually a
decision of is it worth it for me to go
to the mundi to spend usually about like
maybe you know $0.50 like 30 40 rupees
to get like maybe five dollars worth of
value for my produce so oftentimes it's
not a bill just like let them stuff like
rot in their fields and so what are we
doing well we you know it when it we're
basically making an efficient so with
that even if you have like that micro
quantity of produce hey we can bundle
that all together even if you're a big
guy or you're a super small guy everyone
gains by sharing like a truckload and
you're amortized costs kind of going
down okay so this new service should
become profitable right now you're going
to keep digital green as a nonprofit
organization and then are you creating
creating a new legal entity for the
for-profit side yeah that's right so so
basically we do think that there still
remains unmet need from a public good
perspective to help farmers just boost
their production and we think that is
something that the government needs to
invest in and
even we do with like our video
peer-to-peer sharing work but yeah this
loop service like it has to be
competitive to existing other options
that farmers have to like whether
they're taking a bus or a motorbike like
we're saying that our amortized cost is
lesser and more efficient than those
other options so yeah we gotta like beat
them and in a commercial way so I'm
curious will you set it up as a regular
for-profit company are you going to do
something use one of these new social
impact Enterprise social enterprise B
corporation right no yeah right now
we're not trying to do all that
complexity because this is also gonna be
a you know an Indian enterprise so India
does not have all these kinds of
variations to it like corporations or
even nonprofits and actually that has
been a limitation for us which is we are
registered as a as a non-profit in India
and nonprofits in India cannot be doing
this kind of work because even like even
if we're not earning money you can't be
like fundamentally be like your nature
of business can't be helping people not
just mark yes exactly okay so that's
great I want to jump and kind of ask a
question first of all to Radhika
who is using the sustainable development
goals I mean they're so big they're so
broad they're understandable by
everybody but that means that they're
not exactly narrowly defined enough to
be considered business models designed
in a manner that everyone can use them
while the very broad and ambitious
they're sort of sub goals are fairly
detailed not just that they're targets
and indicators where you can even look
at how to measure a subcortical in terms
of who's using it's new but there is in
the philanthropy sector I myself am an
advisor where a lot of the philanthropic
organizations have come together at the
STG philanthropy platform to collaborate
on the business side there is impact at
2030 which Google ritz-carlton and
others have started a consortium where
corporates have come together
to get their employees to volunteer at a
whole different level with the framework
of the sustainable development goals so
in a sense it's a taxonomy that leaders
in almost every sector starting to use
of course the UN is restructuring almost
everything around these goals they don't
give an example of governments as well
all governments have committed but
coming back to India the Indian
government is the Planning Organization
of the Indian government is Anita Yoga
is now completely repurposed to do
things around STDs and the state of
Assam in India is also redoing
everything around these goals STDs is
the acronym for the NGO so much so that
I believe when a government employee
puts an expense report if they don't say
which goal it fits under they won't get
reimbursed so which one exactly so I
think I myself I give you an example
right here at our group Stanford Angels
and entrepreneurs sandwiches people from
the tech comm world of Silicon Valley
Stanford we are starting to look at in
terms of how can we bring the power of
technology to help Society we are doing
a lot of talks and activity around using
them the SDGs as a framework for
everyone to engage the other thing is
doing richer is that people can
collaborate so now if you and Kenya
wants to work on health I can say who
else is working on SDG three and and
people are using that language and so
it's becoming a protocol as well for
global collapse it really and it really
helps the kind of discussion provides
new platforms collaboration and so forth
okay for both of you it all has always
impressed me that South Asia has been
very aware of social problems and the
social entrepreneurship in some ways has
moved further faster there than most
other places in Asia and why why is this
because uh you know as a developing
economy India certainly has big issues
with you know poverty and with hunger
and so forth but so do lots of other
places and
always been curious why do you think
South Asia has really picked up on these
as a major motivation for a lot of
activity I could jump in with my
hypothesis for me I grew up in the
backdrop of the Gandhi Ashram very
steeped in Gandhi and philosophy and
also having read Gandhi a lot my sense
is that that is a it was a father of a
nation in a sense and the when India was
born people were following him today
still many are and he really it wasn't
just that he got India independence for
him it was all about the dignity of the
individual and dignity from
self-reliance and that dignity comes
from being self-employed and caddy the
symbol the kind of gun Gandhi started a
social movement that start using kadhi
kadhi is a fabric which is a symbol of
every rural Indian come up with a simple
view they could spin cloth at home
anyone can do it and then he started a
moment wait it was a call to action to
all Indians to only use cut the part of
it was boycotting British fabric but
part of it was be self-reliant and let's
all help each other be entrepreneurial
everyone who spun a gun kadhi will at
home every villager was a social
entrepreneur in a sense so that spirit
has been there and I think that is that
is probably one of the factors that
don't have a sense for why it's that
when other parts of South Asia I won't
speculate okay Rickon you might comment
on that or maybe from your own
perspective of having started out in
regular you know IT computer companies
right moving into social
entrepreneurship later well yeah I mean
I think like so that the reason why you
know Microsoft Research created this
group technology for emerging markets in
India was because you know basically
they were like there's obviously
Microsoft research labs all around the
world they study like typical areas of
computer science but because of like the
unique place and context that India
represents of people who are not using
technology in the way that we are in the
West that's why they set up this kind of
like academic group and I had no
aspirations of becoming a social
entrepreneur until like it just kind of
like
transpired but I think there's a couple
of things I would say one is definitely
echo like Rebecca's point you know
Gandhi's famous quote you know be be the
change you want to see in the world
right like the whole Ashoka social
entrepreneurship even named kind of his
origins are actually from India this the
second is this kind of like notion of
like jugaad innovation that that is
known in India right where everyone is
is actually just in their own way
whether just that are just like out of
home or they're like in a workplace or
something is just trying to figure out
how I can like amalgamate some
combination of things to like so
InfraGard innovation there's an
interesting term can you explain that
alone it's basically like the more like
an emergent or non-formal totally
structured process of making things work
yeah right to the extent that you can
and I think a lot of that has to do also
with you know the the context right of
like the type of governance structure
that exists in India right like the
largest democracy in the world the fact
that it is also like super large with
such a density of population you know
some initiatives like even our loop
service right
like we don't actually make sense in
other contexts like they don't make
sense in like say a low-density but
still like poverty-stricken place like
same easier why because like the context
is one where there's such a low density
of people sure they're very very poor
and they have a lot of need but there's
like low density of population and low
access to like transportation and like
connectivity kinds of constraints but
that's what's cool about India is like
you got like this population density
where a lot of things kind of like makes
sense and works at like this perfect
storm with all this like technology and
like English and at least like
communications that are on the internet
but a language that is available on the
internet for people to kind of come onto
a common platform that is spurring like
such a revolution and startup ecosystem
in India right you know you probably
have heard about like the whole like
Walmart flip
our deal that just kind of took place a
couple days ago 60 billion below 16
billion dollars yeah cuz Walmart's like
saturated here and and and so this is
like the only last big market for them
and so yeah I mean I encourage everyone
who is interested to immerse yourself
like in a place like India that's the
only way that you can actually innovate
not to do it like from afar I think
because I'm also part of a group called
Rajeev circle and um social
entrepreneurs from there come here every
year fellows from Pakistan and India and
I often wonder they're so doing amazing
things on such no resources completely
entrepreneurs here and I think one
factor might be that when resources are
very limited you innovate and you're way
more resourceful and that is part of
being an entrepreneur as well that's
true actually that's been one of my main
interests in this part of the world I
remember touring around some of the
product development groups and the IITs
and people who are coming up with really
clever solutions that nobody here would
have thought up the idea from here is to
try to take something expensive and make
it cheaper but from there you start from
frugal innovation right let's open the
floor before well okay Walter you go
first
how does this so so hu from new ship
affect their likelihood of the lowest
caste okay how does how does social
entrepreneurship affect the lowest and
and I'm not sure if cast as intentional
but you know group of people it is yeah
I'll give an example of another show
camp fellow and show um who's started an
organization called guns are given a
specific example to answer question in
villages right now in India I'm the
curse system is still there quite a bit
and the most economically under
privileged are the people in the lowest
and often they're not able to come out
of that cycle of poverty and society all
kind of suppression but what this social
entrepreneurs done is he brings you
innovate right in amazing ways he brings
her he has urban Indians kind of share
their the clothes and other things that
they're not using bring them to a
distribution center which is amazing
distribution center all over the big
cities in India he tells them that
you're not doing the favor to rural
Indians we are helping you in helping
you be sustainable so they're doing you
a favor
when he brings those clothes and other
goods to rural India and then he says in
the village the people who are willing
to do community projects help your
community get these things in the
villages the remote villages these
things are precious even old clothes old
computers and what's he's doing it
doesn't go to the power system the the
panchayat system which is of an upper
caste often the lowest caste people come
in they need these things the most and
he empowers them and then they go into
the community projects they have the
best clothes suddenly the status changes
then others come in this is one example
another example is internet sati when a
mansion is often the women from many
different costs who come in and they
teach people how to use the Internet
it's not just a Picasa women it changes
the status so I think social
entrepreneurs really challenge the norm
the cultural norms particularly
including the cosna and I'm sure Ricinus
have thoughts on yeah yeah I mean I
think it is an interesting point
sometimes like technology can sort of
create or exacerbate even like the
asymmetries that exist right in society
as Radhika said right including for like
caste and gender you know for instance
in general access to like mobile phones
by like women is like less than 50
percent than their male counterparts but
like programs like this internet southy
type-1 are trying to like engage like
women so that they have like more
ownership and have more applications
that are of relevance and you know are
sensitive to like how their use cases
similarly for us right like one you know
our transportation service like one call
no barrier that exists is actually for
women that they they can women can go
and buy at marketplaces but they
typically cannot sell at wholesale
markets and so actually what does the
transportation do it allows like the
women farmers who are increasingly more
prevalent because like the male
counterparts have migrated to like the
cities to do like construction work now
they have a way to like have their
produce basically like picked up and and
sold for them and I think kind of behind
what but you both say is any kind of an
entrepreneurial idea has to take the
market for lack of a better word right
the users where they are and help them
move to the next step that they can move
to and so it's a process where it
happens in different steps not all one
thing doesn't solve the whole problem we
were talking about Lou what you see is
two bottleneck the growth assembly you
know it sounds perfectly reasonable in
your presentation but what's like what's
having you not grow as fast as you would
like so the biggest one is a trust
factor right farmers to be trusting that
I can load my bag of produce onto this
truck and that it will be fine
and it will go to like the market place
and I will get back fair value for it
right it's a kind of big behavior change
I don't get the money until the actual
sale happens in the market that's right
we take note we don't we take no such
liability of guaranteeing prices or any
such thing so but the way that we kind
of establish this trust essentially is
that farmers are welcome and to go on
the truck if they want and sometimes
they do especially in the beginning and
then secondly we also push back the
prices that the clearing prices that
that have taken place at market so that
they can kind of corroborate that with
other informal challenge channels that
there anyway speaking like with their
friends and others to be like oh yeah
this was the prevailing market price and
did loop give me that like if yes like
I'm happy if not like I'm gonna have
okay go ahead
why do t is like that a lot of
bargaining happens in the one debate so
the farmer goes and you can't give us
produce and surely the wholesaler will
say oh it's bad produce it's you know
part of it and spoiler two got enough
giving little sprites so these bargains
on behalf at the time basically we there
let me restate real quickly because it's
not showing the question doesn't show up
on the video okay so who bargains on
behalf of the farmers when the produce
gives to market great so basically that
the bargaining is limited there's almost
like none there is some monitoring that
our team actually does like kind of at
the marketplace just to like spot check
that yeah we are actually giving these
farmers like the prevailing market price
but other than that the the reality is
these you know again the fruits and
vegetable space is a little bit
different than the greens marketplace
and with fruits and vegetables it's not
like a typical like auction that's
happening no it's like basically you
just go to like some commission agent
and that guy you know basically is gonna
like swart way the produce sorting
grading away the produce and then he
will determine you know what is the
cause of the price points for each and
the way the bad guy sets his price is
actually not by himself he's a
commission agent so that it actually
it's the next top it's the trader above
him who is actually setting this price
in any case like what we found is that
the fact that there ends up being
variable prices for farmers is actually
a good thing
why because like for farmers it gives
them a direct signal that oh this
produce was of good quality maybe my
buddy and he got a good price and mine
I didn't store properly and so I got a
worse price and so it changes their
behavior over time to like do the right
thing that the market actually wants in
terms of their produce I have kind of a
different follow-up question and that is
the technology that's kind of behind
what you're doing with Lou
yeah why couldn't this have happened
five years ago or you know yeah it could
have been it would have been like way
harder to scale right to like the point
I'm telling you it was at the play to
you there's a couple of things and I
would say like one is this more like
automated brokerage right between like
the farmers to the transporters right an
allocation of who should be routed to
assign to what pick up the payments
thing certainly yes and then there's a
third thing which I didn't actually talk
about which is we basically are able to
capture a ton of transactional data
right because every day you know these
twenty five thousand farmers some subset
of them are using loop to like transact
and so we then get a lot of data about
like okay what was the local wholesale
market prices that commodities cleared
in different marketplaces and what was
the cost to get there and so it
basically helps to like recommend sort
of price arbitrage opportunities for
these farmers to be like should I go to
the you know the wholesale market five
kilometers to my East or five kilometers
to myself they oftentimes they don't
know that like sort of like trade off
and is like pretty simple it's only like
within the five colony radius but it's
only because we have this actual
transactional sales data that we can
actually do that kind of curation and on
the the pickup side the routing side is
that proprietary software that you're
using or how did you develop that yeah
so it is proprietary I would say it's
not as sophisticated but as like as
Cooper right because like uber is
certainly doing like all this like GPS
like location by location like tracking
and minute by minute right like pricing
transporters in India or at least the
transfers we work with we work with
about 850 of them they are not yet
accustomed to that kind of level of
scrutiny and so the way that this
routing routing happens is mostly at a
village to village and market level so
it's like you go to this village first
and that village next and that market
okay fourth right okay great thank right
these are these are great comments thank
you and they love this topic radically
you started off by talking about the
global leaders who are all looking at
these SDGs and sort of buying off of
them and I'm always a little skeptical
when I hear stuff like that probably for
understandable reasons but something you
said actually really struck me when you
talked about how the nonprofit's aren't
allowed to do this type of work and it
got me thinking to what extent are those
government leaders thinking about the
fact that maybe some of the things they
need to change are the rules of the game
in order to allow these things to work
more effectively and more efficiently
and enable social entrepreneurship as
opposed to saying hey we support this so
we want to throw money out or wanna
whatever they might be doing looking at
it as a program to what extent do they
actually step back and say you know what
we actually need to change something
about the way we do things here from a
legal system from a structural system in
order to make this work better so
briefly for the videos yes the SDGs led
to government's looking at regulatory
frameworks to try to improve the ability
of the frameworks to deal with social
entrepreneurship okay so I think I mean
of course I agree that governments are
not the ones are very good at changing
the rules of the game but it's a baby
step I think what what this is doing is
people like us cannot be at the table
people like Reagan and because of the
framework of the goals I again answer
question with an example in the state of
Jharkhand in India which is where
there's a lot of indigenous communities
the Forest Rights Act is the that kind
of determines who gets land rights the
companies who operate there the
government the indigenous communities as
it's being rewritten of a std
philanthropy platform be able to have a
seat at the table now by because we're
looking at SDGs and coming with that
lands and the government is looking at
their stages we have been able to get a
seat at the table by the Amina UN
representatives in country and not just
that be able to say that all of you
looking at who owns what how much but
women are not in the picture if women
indigenous women also had some land
rights it would not just help it's not
just a good thing to do
it would be better for the community
they might actually be more
collaborative and be able to bring those
kind of policy tweaks now it's a very
step but I think that's where the rules
of the game change is going to come from
that now governments are inviting other
stakeholders as they're thinking on SD
g3s tg5 who are the players that said
it's very early days and that on the on
the legal framework again I think it's a
global linker there's a lot happening in
this country right now and our
nonprofits versus for-profit looking at
new forms of legal charters for mission
there's a lot happening in England and
around stds people might collaborate on
this is the hope you had mentioned in
your presentation that there's this kind
of capital gap of about 2.5 trillion
dollars that's needed in order to
address the SDGs I had also seen
separately a report by a business group
looking at business opportunities that
are resulting from the SDGs that was a
huge amount of money I think was
something like in the neighborhood of
somewhere in the tens of trillions of
dollars I remember that the amount they
expected China could benefit by
addressing SDGs
was like five point five trillion and
India was maybe two point five trillion
dollars that could be added to the
economy by you know aggressively
attacking these goals where's the money
gonna come from well it is an ambitious
goal but I think you're touching on them
absolutely the point that it I think all
of us in the space recognize that if the
private sector is not at the table there
just isn't enough money not with all the
philanthropies you and government aid
put together and so it is a moment to
look at I believe the tremendous
business opportunities here and the
country of Kenya for example the UN is
welcoming private sector big global
companies to come to the table they want
to achieve universal health care the
saying come here work with us we'll
design policy to make it a business
lucrative for you but let's all look at
the
goal of solving healthcare and that said
there's also an opportunity to reframe a
bit things them people and healthcare
people already in education people are
in the food industry so their stages
also offer an opportunity to look at
things with a different lens but the key
thing is I think where are the business
cases for achieving this videos and
engaging private sector and the other
change I think is from within to the
degree some of the big companies are
starting to think about these goals and
kind of thinking bring it on the core
mission not just CSR groups yeah that is
another factor that's going to affect
things in countries like India India the
2% CSR law that every every corporate is
required to give 2% now many of those
are looking at can we do things those
around SDS and bring it into the core
mission of the company so I think that
that's one of these things where you do
see the role of government and then the
role of industry and there's this nice
overlap space provided there's not a gap
yes are you concerned that the
government's are not going to support
the framework needed for doing good
entrepreneurship I mean and this is one
of those things where entrepreneurs say
we're changing the world for the better
right but a lot of people have this kind
of attitude that business is just there
to make money and somehow in that space
you have to have a really good social
impact business mindset right yes are
you concerned that these two might not
overlap so well I am cautiously
concerned I'm also an optimist I'm an
uber optimist I feel that the SDGs
can catalyze they're quite action to
government's to the private sector to
everybody everywhere sit is at every
organization to find that kind of
collaboration and come together to
achieve these but that's what I think
people are quick in the social
entrepreneurs of this world you can
bring that spirit to everybody in every
organization I think people are coming
in with for the most part the right
mindset and they want to do this I'm
more concerned about will they be able
to achieve this because it's non-trivial
even with the writing
so that that is a challenge but I think
we cannot afford to not aim to achieve
this considering how bad the crisis is
in the world okay Rickon what's in the
future for digital green so you've got
the Luke project there's an awful lot of
scale and you can do it that that's good
that could become huge
right but is digital green going to
continue to look for new kinds of
innovation what do you see as the future
for your organization yeah I mean I
think we think about like our work kind
of in like sort of like how technology
people think about like stacking
different layers of intervention one on
top of the other like so our base layer
is like these videos produced by and for
farmers to like blues production we now
like have this like loop thing that is
like to efficiently connect the first
top markets we hope to like be able to
stack on top of that is I think mainly
two things one is basically like a
futures market type of play for farmers
right to basically pre plan their
production as per market demand because
even it like there's one downside to our
whole approach right before like the
loop service which is if we're super
successful we may bite ourselves with
the fact that we've now made it super
efficient to crash market prices right
because we've been able to like increase
supply to them so that's not good so we
definitely need to like be thinking
about how we might be able to like in
advance of the season help farmers
figure out like should I grow carrots
versus tomatoes versus cauliflower and
in what quantities given that probably
there's some market for carrots but it's
like not probably as big as like onions
and tomatoes and so we need to like be
distributing sort of like effort so
that's really where I added a neighbor's
economic enablers from the government
role in private sector is there a role
for like the World Bank to be a banker
for these type of
activities and making it a little bit
more of a venture capital type of model
so what is the role of international
institutions like the World Bank I think
there's definitely a role but again I
think it's going to have to be things
different than the way they've been done
and looking there's there are so many
things happening with different green
and blue bonds a lot of innovation
happening in how we finance some of this
work and development finance as well and
I think the key thing is every the
important thing here is going to be that
every actor comes to the table with some
humility recognizing none of us know the
answers because we have complex
challenges how can we all together
figure out what needs to be done this I
think is particularly the point that was
in our governments World Bank un
particularly important that these
organizations also look at how social
entrepreneurs are doing things and bring
some of that spirit into the
organizations it's going to be very
important that said those roles are very
important because we need to scale and
we need to scale fast and the UN the
World Bank I'm a believer also the big
organizations can have used impact but
we need do two things differently than
the way we've been doing them that I'm
convinced how do you convince them to do
that I think by bringing them together
in a room and discussions I think it's
by collaboration and having people in
roundtables that's why we do this STG
philanthropy platform where we have UN
government philanthropy pelini a lot
more like that and we need people like
freaking on forums like this talking
about how they do things and we can you
have a common wrong I was just gonna say
you know I was also I was at an event in
the state of Andhra Pradesh where Bill
Gates and the Chief Minister of Andhra
Pradesh Naidu
were there and basically what what the
Chief Minister was basically talking
about was how 20 years ago he worked
with Bill Gates to like introduce the IT
industry to hide their BOTS by setting
up basically Microsoft India and and
that spurred like a crazy ecosystem that
we all know know and now what they're
talking about is can we do the same for
like say and you feel like our field of
like AG tech
so basically can we do 84 IT what's kind
of their whole thing but one thing I
want to say was that I think there are
there are inherent tensions unlike all
these things which are like sometimes
hard to reconcile right and the one that
that you know I guess we've seen like
first hand which is rural communities
are a major constituency for politicians
right so they do want to protect their
interests and everyone we also want to
protect their interest right but on the
other hand sometimes that goes far right
which is like maybe they're gonna like
limit something like foreign direct
investment in a sector like agriculture
because they think that some corporation
is going to harm farmers right which is
a constituency so how do you reconcile
those two like kind of competing
interests of like FDI may be necessary
to like boost like investment into a
into a sector that really needs it on
the other hand like you want to do it in
a way that's not harmful to like the
people who are obviously at like a low
like kind of like purchasing power base
that actually kinda brings up a point in
theories of innovation that there is a
way of looking at innovation that it
always creates a class of winners on the
class of losers you know the people who
move ahead and they're the people who
are left behind and this is an area
where I've run into people at
international conferences who are pretty
much any innovation because it's bad for
the common people
okay how do you include the common
people I mean of course the farmers are
doing well but how do you make sure that
these projects have kind of an inclusive
approach to benefit as many people as
possible
I guess that's first to you yeah I again
I think the sustainable development
goals provide us that framework I'm the
one of the spirit codified in the goals
is leave no one behind
so if you when you innovate you're
innovating to a purpose if you start
with innovation where one of the
non-negotiables are that we don't want
to leave anyone behind then we get that
automatically and I think we
need innovation of a different sort
right now not the kind that Silicon
Valley innovation to make more money for
the elite but innovation there is there
to tackle the SDGs and do that one of
the professor's here professor Barney
Banerjee is a very interesting way of
doing this he calls its systems
acupuncture look at where are the areas
and opportunities to achieve them STDs
and level the playing field for all and
then think of nonlinear innovation in
those areas and if we design innovation
that way I think it can't be actually a
game changer and helping have more
equality rather than the other way
around okay do you have to worry about
big agribusiness and what you're doing
or they just not in the picture right
now uh certainly there we've been
approached by big agribusiness but we've
mostly stayed away and mainly because
big agribusiness typically it is like
interested in just kind of like selling
more of their product
yeah I've got some seed I've got some
fertilizer and I want to distribute it
so that's not like our mission really to
like help other people sell more product
and like there's we also have like a
little bit of like a kind of a theory of
change which is sure eventually farmers
do need to like probably buy particular
things that can like improve their
productivity but that's not step one the
step one is boost production boost
income by connecting with market then
invest right in that really is different
than the typical businesses mentality
and this is you know kind of an exciting
good approach to innovation oh okay
time for another few questions I see
several hands you go first and then you
okay and it's in about
have you thought about potentially
integrating autonomous vehicles maybe
solved that trust and efficiency issue
we're talking about so the future
autonomous vehicles for loot that would
might help the trust issue yeah I think
so the farmers aren't like not just
trusting not trusting the the trucker
they're also not not trusting the guy at
the market right where the produce is
sold so I think one there's fundamental
challenges with regard to like the
introduction of autonomous vehicles
whether aerial or ground-based in like
an environment like rural India for like
the kind of volumes where you're dealing
with like bulky stuff right like
cauliflower all right in like a one-ton
quantity so like aerial stuff is kind of
out now you're like on ground and yeah
your options of navigation are pretty
poor in these rural environments that
you know although like Road connectivity
is really been increasing across India
it still is it still would be a super
big challenge to like figure out like
can you do that well and then secondly
fundamentally I think it's I don't think
it addresses the trust issue necessarily
there were two hands over here okay
behind you is first okay good
you mentioned protectionism in India a
little bit there's also like a lot of
corruption slimy politicians I'm sure
there's a fruits and vegetable mafia
that's gonna want to cut up the profits
of loot it could be maybe if you could
speak a little bit to the unique kind of
challenges of India of doing business in
India and and kind of how do you not let
that be a deterrent as you're working
yeah it's a good question um so you know
like our core like kind of like the
video nonprofit kind of like work that
we've been doing for like you know 11
years we do that actually very closely
with government and you know the
government itself is not like a monolith
there's parts that are strong and weak
whether you talk about it like at a
sectoral level like that's why we
partner with the Ministry of Rural
Development because
we like them and they're there like have
a strong sort of alignment with regard
to their strategy and ours and then also
like when you look at it state-by-state
level like India is like really big and
every state is pretty diverse even when
you talk about its governance and so
there are certainly specific states that
we've had more success in and then
there's other states like we've just not
even gone to because like they just
don't have the investments of
infrastructure or people or whatever
budget for them to even play with us
yeah so that's one with regard to like
the the corruption issue we have not
really faced it the main reason is
agriculture and rural development is
like the sector that has not that much
money
right so if you're a corrupt person like
you should go to another sector like the
Public Works Department you should go to
defense these are good sectors like
agriculture like there's not much money
to be had here even like your what are
you gonna do is like steal like a truck
of carrots yeah we've got stopped by
like police like who have like been like
hey maybe we do want to see all your
chocolate cards but like that's a you
know petty like kind of like corruption
we don't see like the massive kind of
like corruption that that probably still
exists but in other sectors okay go
ahead or have you done it where the
seller can pay through Paytm at a
discount to the farmer wow the thing is
being loaded while the while the objects
are being loaded onto the truck oh yes
so that's basically the idea like what
you're suggesting is basically the idea
of the futures market auction so
actually what we've done is not to do
like an in advance like because like
this is a massive change of behavior
like no traders or farmers have ever
like set contracts with each other in
advance before those yeah but so the way
that we're doing it is with these very
same farmers and traders who we've been
working with for two years and they've
been just trading and getting like the
spa
price right they take them produce to
market and then spot price they pay them
back so with the only new like sort of
nudge that we're trying with them is to
be like one day before just give us your
sell orders farmers with your min price
that you're willing to sell it up and
trader
what's your buy order and what's your
max price that you're willing to pay and
basically run an auction contract them
put in like a deposit right that you've
contracted so that you don't like run
away and then yeah and then basically at
the time of loading you're already like
locked in right to a deal so this yeah
it's pretty more recent for us and it is
a really big change in behavior and so
we're basically letting the farmers and
traders experiment so either they can
use a subset of produce and do it spot
or do the futures kind of play a
question that we trying to understand it
that's organizational structure to
address social problems we've got a wide
range of options here we've got such
enterprise because CSR outer private
sector complete with patent GL's we've
got weird kind of structural companies
like Salt Works they actually took
states are as a pillar of their
businesses so just in your view with the
advantages and disadvantages of social
enterprises addressing side oil problems
person it's the other approaches that's
a great question right oh sure sure I
think it's um there's so many different
so so main thing is that if we look at
the CSR groups often it is for helping
society but often there's also branding
advantage to the company right so so how
do you kind of balance that and on
similarly on I think the big challenge
with social enterprises I think the big
benefit with social enterprises a new
fields I'll touch on that and I buy
social enterprise I'm in the very keen
you stood double bottom line
entrepreneurs are looking to have
profits revenues and have social mission
the positive is that you own a very
sustainable
and that is much needed right now so
many amazing social entrepreneurs are
nonprofit spend so much of the time
fundraising it is a different power
dynamic sometimes when there's a grantee
versus where a social enterprise and
your equity partner you're more a
partner so this some advantages there on
the flip side I think comes in the
factor of it's at this moment I think
it's harder to raise capital actually
because the philanthropist often only
fund the nonprofit's the investors even
some of the impact investors are used to
funding for profit that and there is an
inherent mindset often that you think
that if there is a social impact there
must be it will be lower profits so it's
very hard to get seed capital for social
enterprise but the second second I would
call it a disadvantage but something to
think about is as a social enterprise if
you truly want to also achieve mission
you have trade of these two things the
two goals making profits and having
mission and how do you turn the Neman is
really really tough how are you going to
make those trade-offs is going to be
very important and there is a whole
spectrum of investors and entrepreneurs
how they'll make those trade-offs there
is no standards really in a sense so
that is one of the challenges and on the
impact investing side again is a
spectrum that people some are doing it
for branding then there are there are
philanthropic foundations who are
getting into impact investing as a way
of doing the very mission driven that's
the whole spectrum in between and so so
in all of this again I think having a
common language on what how much mission
is okay at least transparency so
everyone knows that if I'm a social
enterprise this much weight urgent
mission and this merchant profits even
if that was communicated that would be
powerful and I just want to give one
example if I may I'm richer because
there is something because his mind said
that you can't make money while you
can't be as good as just business
entrepreneurs just there to make money I
want to share that and since we are
talking of agriculture at Stanford
Angels one of our investments early
investments was a company called blue
river technologies in the entry field
robotics and the business school
graduates came together and started
broad robotics and computer
to transform the farming industry and
what they came up with is a very
low-cost way of reducing the amount of
herbicides used bringing automated
thinning of like crops where you need to
get rid of lot of the original lease on
crops so it's been it's really disrupted
agriculture industry here recently and
the reason I mentioned them that they
were quiet for 305 million by John T
recently because of the industry and
tech disruption there and this is an
example of a mission-driven
and a social enterprise that actually
got very good returns for investors so
it is very doable it's just harder
especially if it's not in the core
strategy to think of both mission and
profits but I also had an exit and this
is an interesting concept yeah dealing
with a social enterprise yeah exit is
often something more to do a
sustainability than it is with
maximizing capital gain and not that it
can't maximize capital gains we had your
point but that's a great complex answer
to a complex situation we're about out
of time I'm gonna ask one last question
to both of you and we'll we'll adjourn
and have informal discussion over
refreshments so there are lots of new
opportunities technology is the oil
that's making this whole kind of
endeavor go much better than it ever has
before
what advice would you give to someone
who is considering either making an
investment in their own time or
investment of money and some sort of
social enterprise o be the advice I
would say look at what's happening with
cutting-edge technology the kind of
efficiencies and possibilities are just
unprecedented and don't fear technology
of course be very thoughtful on the
negative externalities but what able to
do with AI at this moment and big data
analytics is very transformative so look
at what's there and think of it as
augmenting what you're doing not as a
substitute okay thank you I guess one
one sort of like reflection that we've
had over these years is that
technology is really only good at
magnifying human intent and capability
and related to like Robbie cos points if
those things that are not right or not
fully built then things couldn't easily
go awry even with like the best of
intentions yeah and so what we found
success and what you know what I'd say
like to spend time is like to think
about like how technology is sort of
like building on perhaps foundational
sort of existing infrastructure
investments in like people institutions
finance and political systems if those
things are somewhat reasonable then like
something like some technology like
whether it's videos by and for farmers
or transportation or some other totally
different thing like that's when you'll
find like those have the most effect and
both in terms of like shareholder value
and an ultimate like impact for the
community so that it serves okay that's
great thanks everyone for coming please
join me in thanking our panelists this
was great
[Applause]